dunkle tunnel voller knochen und schädel
ein ort für teufelsanbeter für rituale
um die toten zu kontaktieren
[Musik]
eine zerstörte festungsanlage
normalerweise dominieren bauwerke die
landschaft ist es andersrum hier hat
sich die natur ihr terrain zurückerobert
[Applaus]
eine stadt in der die zeit stehen
geblieben ist
sie wirkt geradezu surreal wie eine
verfluchte geisterstadt freund ingo star
seltsame bauten im meer
keine straße führt da ist sonst nichts
warum wurden sie hier gebaut
[Musik]
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten
dann wurden die anlagen aufgegeben
manche sind heute lebensgefährlich
verseucht
doch wer waren ihre erbauer wie wurden
sie errichtet und warum wurden sie
verlassen
an der grenze zwischen kalifornien und
nevada stehen die überreste einer stadt
die einst bedeutend war und gefährlich
[Musik]
die offenste ich wie am filmset eines
westerns
im moment kann ein revolverheld um die
ecke kommen
[Musik]
das ist irgendwie unheimlich die gebäude
wirken intakt aber niemand lebt dort nur
der wind pfeift durch die häuser
[Musik]
auf den tischen und stühlen hat sich im
lauf der jahre eine dicke staubschicht
gebildet
das alles wirkt geradezu surreal
die häuser sehen aus wie früher aber
alles andere rostet vor sich hin und
verfällt
[Musik]
einige gebäude sind eingestürzt
ein anderer könntest du sofort einziehen
[Musik]
am stadtrand befindet sich die ruine
einer fabrik sie ist der schlüssel zu
allem was hier geschehen ist
aber irgendetwas scheint zu fehlen
man kommt dann eine kreuzung an der die
hauptstraße anfangen müsste
das sind keine häuser
es scheint als wäre die stadt früher
viel größer gewesen
[Musik]
in späten neunzehnten jahrhundert
tummeln sich in den straßen noch
abenteurer und goldsucher die hier ihr
glück finden wollen
[Musik]
du bist praktisch am ende der welt
selbst heute ist da weit und breit
nichts
dann so einen ort kommst du nur wegen
des geldes
etwas wertvolles finden und später
verkaufen
offensichtlich muss es sich einmal
gelohnt haben an diesem staubigen und
zweifellos gefährlichen ort zu kommen
[Musik]
der westen war absolutes neuland ein ort
ohne recht und gesetz der wilde westen
eben jeder war auf sich allein gestellt
[Musik]
das trockene klima hat die häuser gut
erhalten aber sie sind nur ein bruchteil
der ehemaligen stadt die parkranger
catherine jones erklärt
[Musik]
fünf der häuser die hier mal gestanden
haben
es gibt zwar noch viele häuser
die hauptstraße war früher ein zwei
kilometer lang und ich bescheuert
[Musik]
hinter all dem steckt nur eines gold
willkommen in der geisterstadt bei audi
[Musik]
in den leeren straßen tummelten sich
einst an die 10.000 glückssucher
[Musik]
und für interessant ist nicht was da
noch ist sondern was fehlt und das ist
eine menge aber wo ist es hin und warum
am anfang war hier nicht viel los
man erwarte keine großen gold vorkommen
geschafft wurde oben auf den
die minen dann ungefähr da wo jetzt
immer noch die alten zu sehen sind
[Musik]
in den ersten wird nicht viel gold
gefunden aber dann stürzt ein bergwerk
ein und alles ändert sich
der einsturz lebte eine reiche goldader
frei
rudy wurde gegründet
plötzlich war der name bo die ein
begriff
jeder wollte dahin und ein stück vom
kuchen abhaben
verarbeitungsanlagen wie diese laufen
rund um die uhr
[Musik]
sie steht am stadtrand und vermittelt
einen eindruck vom umfang der produktion
[Musik]
das ist der hauptraum des stammwerks
gold und silber erz kam in diese gefäße
mit den tausend pfund schweren stand
sie gingen 90 mal pro minute auf und
nieder rund um die uhr sechs tage die
woche
[Musik]
der aufwand macht sich bezahlt
wo die schwimmt im geld
während der boomjahre verdienen die
bergbauunternehmen um die 100 millionen
dollar
die stadt verzeichnet tag für tag 10
neuankömmlinge
willkommen beim kalifornischen
goldrausch
es ist bereits der dritte große
amerikanische goldrausch des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts damals gehört kalifornien
noch nicht zu den vereinigten staaten
aber nach den ersten goldfunden im jahr
1849 strömen arbeiter aus georgia und
south carolina um ihr glück zu machen
dutzende unternehmen folgen ihnen um die
reichhaltigen bodenschätze abzubauen
die folge kalifornien wird teil der usa
[Musik]
wie war das las vegas seiner zeit da gab
es nichts was du nicht kaufen oder
verkaufen konnte ist ein paradies für
gesetzlose auf der suche nach dem
schnellen geld
[Musik]
1879 hat wo wir schon 2000 neue gebäude
die neuankömmlinge brauchen schließlich
ein dach über dem kopf
leider bringt der goldrausch aber auch
das schlechte im menschen zum vorschein
einmal berichteten die zeitungen das in
der vorwoche ausnahmsweise niemand
umgebracht worden war
offensichtlich eine premiere
die wurde hart gearbeitet
[Musik]
am nordrand der stadt liegt das
rotlichtviertel mit seinen bordellen und
opiumhöhlen hier herrschen raue sitten
1892 wird es von einer feuersbrunst
heimgesucht
[Musik]
ein feuer brach aus und verbreitete sich
in windeseile aus die häuser waren aus
holz da hatte es leichtes spiel es
dauerte nicht lange bis dieser teil des
vollständig abgebrannt war
mit den ausschweifungen für die boni
berüchtigt ist hat das feuer aber nichts
zu tun
die wurden buchstäblich über nacht
errichtet sobald irgendwo anders gold
gefunden wurde zogen die leute weiter
zurück geblieben wäre holzhäuser jetzt
im trockenen klima die katastrophe war
programmiert
1881 zehntausende weg 1892 als sich das
feuer ereignete standen viele häuser
leer und brannten ab sie wurden nie
wieder aufgebaut
das feuer war nur der anfang
noch weitere katastrophen die body
schließlich von der karte verschwinden
ließen
der schleichende niedergang geht bis
1932 weiter dann folgt ein weiteres
großfeuer es ist der anfang vom ende für
die alte westernstadt
[Musik]
das feuer rauschte die hauptstraße
runter und machte fast alles zunichte
ein paar zähne bewohner bleiben bis in
die vierziger jahre
ihre spuren sind bis heute erhalten
es ist nicht mehr da aber was noch übrig
ist wird die zeit stehengeblieben
[Musik]
war eine boomtown aber wie sie in hilfe
steht
wahnsinnig erfolgreich in vergessenheit
geraten so war das überall im will
direkt unter den beliebten boulevards
von paris verbirgt sich ein dunkles
geheimnis
[Musik]
es ist einer der unheimlichsten orte der
welt
ein adler berühmt
bist du mitten in der unterwelt
sowas gibt's nicht noch mal
[Musik]
verzierte tunnel ziehen sich endlos
durch den feuchten felsen
die verzierung genau anschauen und ihr
klar wird woraus sie sind merkst du dass
es sich um etwas völlig anderes handelt
wände verändern sich nicht gleich warum
aber dann bemerkst du dass das keine
felsen sind sondern menschliche knochen
und
[Musik]
große knochen sind regelrecht
künstlerisch auf gestattet
aber es bleiben doch menschliche knochen
eine verstörende mischung aus tanz kunst
es ist erschreckend wie
fasziniert
dieser ort ist alles andere als ein
gewöhnliches knochen grad
verrückte ort
es muss ein grund dafür gegeben haben
etwas wovon die ganze stadt wusste so
was großes kannst du nicht geheim halten
warum sind so viele tote direkt unter
einer der größten metropolen der welt
begraben
[Musik]
die endlosen knopf stabel säumen die
tunnel seit etwa 200 jahren
[Musik]
für die meisten von ihnen ist es nicht
die erste ruhestätte
im 18 jahrhundert ist paris die
zweitgrößte stadt europas
ein zentrum für philosophie und
wissenschaft es ist das zeitalter der
aufklärung
zwischen 1720 und
1760 verdoppelt sich die zahl der bücher
über wissenschaft und kunst der
religiöse publikationen dagegen sind auf
dem rückzug paris besitzt große
strahlkraft von überall in europa
strömen intellektuelle in diesen
metropolen
die friedhöfe haben keinen platz für die
wachsende kundschaft
überall in der stadt gab es friedhöfe
und sie waren auch noch hoffnungslos
überfüllt die leichen stapelten sich
förmlich
die straßen waren geradezu von einem
widerlichen gestand geschwängert
nichts deutet heute darauf hin doch im
achtzehnten jahrhundert ist an dieser
stelle der sogenannte friedhof der
unschuldigen saison im lauf seiner 800
jährigen geschichte wurden hier zwei
millionen pariser beigesetzt
[Musik]
selbst der größte friedhof ist
irgendwann voll trotzdem wurden immer
noch mehr tote beigesetzt
wegen des platzmangels wurden die alten
knochen ausgegraben und unter den
dächern der umliegenden häuser verstaut
es war nur eine frage der zeit bis sich
das rächen musste
der frühling des jahres 1780 ist
ungewöhnlich feucht der regen ist zu
viel für das alte friedhofs gemäuer
[Musik]
alles saugte sich voll
die bauern konnten dem nicht standhalten
und brachen
eine mischung aus durchweichte erde und
verwesenden leichen wurde in die oben
liegenden straßen gespült
die archäologen sylvie robert berichtet
wie die französischen behörden auf den
vorfall reagiert
die anwohner wurden vom arzt untersucht
aus sicherheitsgründen musste die
umgebung evakuiert werden
es war buchstäblich
übergelaufen
eine lösung musste her und zwar schnell
ist
die den tunnel sind der ausweg die
katakomben von paris
wichtige pariser bauwerke wie der louvre
sind aus kalkstein
ursprünglich stammte das material aus
steinbrüchen vom stadtrand später
entstanden steinbrüche direkt unterhalb
der stadt
angeblich ist der stollen netz 300
kilometer lang
von menschenhand geschaffen heute direkt
unter paris die wenigsten wussten von
seiner existenz
die karten zeigen ein weit verzweigtes
netz aus tunneln und schächten unter der
ganzen stadt
einige davon werden fortan als letzte
ruhestätte genutzt
im dezember 1785 beginnt der umzug der
gebeine in die katakomben
das war eine grausige und zugleich hoch
komplexe operation
leichen aus mehreren jahrhunderten
wurden ausgegraben nachts auf wagen
geladen und in die katakomben gebracht
insgesamt an die sechs millionen
wir stehen hier am grund eines schachts
durch den ursprünglich die steine nach
oben befördert wurden
später wurden hier die gebeine 20 meter
nach unten in die katakomben geworfen
danach wurden die knochen auf die gänge
verteilt
[Musik]
nacht für nacht wurden zahllose knochen
nach unten gebracht
bizarrer angelegenheit
[Musik]
der transport dauert mehrere jahrzehnte
die knochen hier erwecken nicht den
eindruck als seien sie achtlos oder bloß
platzsparend auf gestapelt
welches rätselhafte system steckt hinter
der anordnung
wir befinden uns 20 meter unter der
strasse direkt unter dem 14 diesmal
hier sehen wir eine kreuzförmige
dekoration mit schädeln in einer wand
aus knochen
einige der schädel sind von vorne zu
sehen
hinter der wand sind weitere knochen
gelagert
geht es nur um ökonomische nutzung des
raums oder steckt eine tiefere bedeutung
hinter der geheimnisvollen anordnung
[Musik]
kein generalinspekteur versuchte der
knochenmasse herr zu werden
er entwickelte das konzept für eine
ästhetische anordnung der gebeine die
besucher anlocken und zum nachdenken
über den tod anregen sollte
er wollte den knochen haufen in etwas
verwandeln das eine seele hat
er gab den toten ihre würde zurück
besucher sollten zum denken angeregt
werde
1860 werden die letzten gebeine in die
katakomben gebracht
wer heute hier landet ist quicklebendig
und kehrt nach überstandener große tour
wieder zurück an die oberfläche
[Musik]
noch immer sind die katakomben bei
touristen sehr beliebt
und erzielen oftmals einen erstaunlichen
effekt
[Musik]
es ist wirklich bemerkenswert
die meisten besucher verlassen die
katakomben in geradezu gehobener
stimmung
dieser ort hat eine seele und
ist voller energie
[Musik]
ein ort voller widerstreitender
emotionen
kunst anbetung geschichte und erinnerung
[Musik]
im nachbarland belgien am rand von
lüttich um wald der deutschen grenze
stehen die zerstörten überreste eines
gigantischen baus
[Musik]
es ist ein ort der zerstörung etwas sehr
brutales muss hier stattgefunden haben
verändern bauwerke die landschaft wie
sieht es so aus als hätte die erde
versucht die architektur zurück in den
boden zu ziehen
teile der anlage sind dreieckig mit
unten elementen es ist ein hässlicher
irgendwie beunruhigend ein riesiges
areal mit zerstörtem beton und starten
[Musik]
mehrere solcher rätselhaften betonkoloss
sind rund um die stadt verteilt
[Musik]
aber keiner sieht so schlimm aus wie
dieser
was die ganze anlage ist so riesig und
ausgefeilt man ahnt dass dahinter etwas
großes
wie wurde etwas so mächtiges zu etwas so
erbärmlichen
nach den zahlreichen kriegen des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts werden in
belgien diverse abwehr stellungen
errichtet darunter
1888 auch diese festung
es war eine der modernsten stellung in
ihrer zeit mit
[Musik]
das beste was europäische
militärtechnologie zu bieten hatte
25 jahre lang passiert nichts aber dann
zieht ein gewaltiger sturm auf
der erste weltkrieg
nach dem niedergang des osmanischen
reichs versucht deutschland seine macht
auszubauen
frankreich misstraut dem erzfeind
sowieso aber als österreich ungarn und
das deutsche kaiserreich eine allianz
bilden schritt sämtliche alarmglocken
sicherheitshalber bilden frankreich
russland und das vereinigte königreich
ihr eigenes bündnis die sogenannte
triple
[Musik]
ist eine art puffer zwischen deutschland
und frankreich
deshalb muss es auf angriffe aus dem
osten vorbereitet sein
deutschland sieht sich von feinden
umgeben und europa steuert auf den
großen knall zu
[Musik]
die gegend rund um lüttich eignet sich
am besten für einen einmarsch
wenn du belgien vor einer deutschen
invasion schützen will
die ruhigen tage sind vorbei schon bald
soll der festungs ring einer modernen
armeen standhalten eine herkulesaufgabe
für fonds
[Musik]
hat die festung gebaut wurden waren sie
im grunde unbezwingbar
kein um 1880 bekannte waffe konnte diese
mauern durchbrechen
ist experte für die geschichte der
festung
die leute wähnten sich in sicherheit
es gab damals weltweit keine anderen
festungen mit betonwänden und mit
stahlkugeln geschützte artillerie
als flachbau bietet die festung aus der
ferne kaum angriffsfläche
oben befinden sich verschiedene
einsehbare rotierende geschütztürme
wer trotzdem bis zur festung vordringt
bekommt es mit einer hoch aufragenden
mauer und tiefen schutz gräben zu tun
eine tödliche falle
dieser graben ist die äußere
verteidigungslinie des fonds wer es bis
hierher schafft er wurde von
artilleriegeschützen erwartet
in diesen ecken standen zwei geschützt
sie feuerten 196 bleikugeln in alle
richtungen ab
die kanonen sind winter panzer wenden
sie bieten freie sicht auf die gebogenen
seitenwände von denen ab rheine kugeln
umgelenkt werden
[Applaus]
hier gibt es kein entrinnen
die belgischen soldaten sind derweil in
den unterirdischen räumen der festung
sicher postiert
[Musik]
hier stand eine 5,7 millimeter kanone
sie nahm den graben unter beschuss da
hatte kein eindringling eine chance
[Musik]
1914 beginnt der erste weltkrieg
lüttich ist sofort in der schusslinie
ist
teil der umfangreichen abwehr stellungen
mit denen sich die stadt gegen einen
angriff widmet
[Musik]
erinnern die deutschen daran hindern
kann die mars zu überqueren
dann kann man sie auch daran hindern in
frankreich einzumarschieren
ich hatte so große strategische
bedeutung
dass ein einzelnes vorher nicht
ausreichten
deshalb wurden rund herum 12 festungen
errichtet
ein stabiles verteidigungs netz sollte
man meinen
doch die deutschen rücken mit vier
millionen soldaten an
belgien hat nur 200.000
respekt für die belgier machten dem
deutschen reich keine angst die
deutschen erwarteten keinen widerstand
die deutschen griffen überfallartig
ahnen und genauso schnell werten die
belgier sie ab für ein oder zwei tage
funktionierte der abwehr und unnötig
sehr gut
es folgt ein weiterer schwerer angriff
der deutschen und diesmal kommen sie bis
ins stadtzentrum
sie haben eine wunderwaffe mit der die
belgier nicht gerechnet haben
[Musik]
sogenannte dicke berta war damals das
größte geschützt der welt 142 cm moerser
sie rückt mit einem riesen geschoss auf
rädern an und feierten panzerbrechende
munition direkt in die mauern der
belgischen abwehr stellung
mit einer reichweite von 15 kilometern
bedroht die dicke berta auch die weiter
entfernten festungen vor langsam die
neue kommandozentrale der belgischen
verteidigung gerät bald ins visier der
deutschen offensive
hat die dicke berta allein diese schäden
angerichtet
oder führte etwas anderes zu dieser
massiven zerstörung
die festungen rundum nötig wurden gebaut
um es mit den stärksten waffen des
späten 19
nach zweitägigem beschuss
traf die dicke berta mit ihrem 25
treffer das unterirdische munitionslager
alles flog in die luft
körperteile
[Musik]
das pure inferno
der letzte schuss durchschlägt das
zweieinhalb meter dicke dach und bringt
zwölf tonnen munition zum explodieren
eine enorme druckwelle entsteht
350 männer kommen ums leben
falls alles flog in die luft
die betonklötze schossen nur so durch
die gegend
es war die hölle wie ein vulkanausbruch
nach 15 oder 20 sekunden war alles
vorbei
das problem war dass beton in den 1800
80er jahren noch ohne stahlarmierung
gegossen wurde
den kanonen des zwanzigsten jahrhundert
hielt er nicht stand
die belgier sind geschlagen gegen die
zahlenmäßige und technischen übermacht
des deutschen reichs können sie nichts
ausrichten
aber nicht alles ist vergeblich
[Musik]
solche festungen haben den zweck den
gegner auf zeiten hin zu bremsen das
gelang sehr gut
am ende erwies sich die zerstörung des
chors als strategischer erfolg für
belgien frankreich und das vereinigte
königreich
die deutschen wurden in nötig so lange
aufgehalten dass die französischen und
britischen truppen sich neu aufstellen
und die deutschen vom erreichen ihrer
ziele abhalten könnten
ohne den hartnäckigen belgischen
widerstand
wenige wochen gewonnen
350 soldaten sterben bei der
verteidigung des fonds sie sind unter
den ruinen begraben
wir dürfen diese männer nicht vergessen
deshalb bewahren wir diesen ort als
denkmal als ruhestätte als teil unserer
erinnerung
[Musik]
vor der küste floridas stehen mitten im
wasser seltsame bauwerke
aus der ferne sehen sie fast lebendig
aus
unglaublich
wie von einem anderen planeten
es wirkt unheimlich ist es was
militärisches eine forschungseinrichtung
sowas könnten ein paar verrückte mönche
vor den griechischen inseln gebaut haben
oder dreimal
das
ungewöhnliche design lässt vermuten dass
hier etwas revolutionäres entstehen
sollte
sehr ambitioniertes dahinter wer immer
die dinge gebaut hat wollte damit
grenzen sprengen
wir sind weit entfernt von jeglicher
zivilisation da es sonst weit und breit
nichts mitten im nirgendwo aber das
scheint den erbauer nicht gestört zu
haben er war offenbar sehr selbstbewusst
und hatte großes vertrauen in das
projekt
wozu also dienten die kugelförmigen
gebilde
und wieso stehen sie ausgerechnet hier
[Musik]
wir sind unterwegs nach cape romano das
gehört zur inselgruppe der 10.000
islands das wasser ist hier nur gut ein
meter tief wir müssen also aufpassen
fast täglich laufen hier boote aufgrund
captain chris riley kommt seit 20 jahren
hierher er kennt die gefahren die unter
den wellen lauern aber
wasser ist noch das geringste problem
die gibt es regelmäßig wirbelstürme wir
müssen ständig mit unruhiger sie rechnen
die küste floridas ist nicht gerade
ideales bauland wenn du da etwas paust
musst du es wirklich ernst meinen
du bist dort wind und wetter komplett
ausgeliefert
das kann ganz schön gefährlich werden
es mag verrückt erscheinen diesen ort
für ein bauprojekt auszuwählen
für den ehemaligen ölproduzenten bobby
aber kommt kein anderer in frage
als bobby diesen küstenstreifen
entdeckte war es um ihn geschehen
aber anders als andere denen es ähnlich
ging wollte er hier nicht nur ein
ferienhäuschen und golf spielen er
wollte raus in die natur
die gegen ein wenig kennt weiß wie
gefährlich sie ist
[Musik]
als lee dort mit seinem bauprojekt
anfing in alle für durchgeknallt
aber dies ist kein gewöhnliches
bauprojekt dies ist ließ traum dass kate
romano dem haus
[Musik]
das konzept futuristisch aber es ist
eine altmodische vorstellung von der
zukunft
wie aus den 60er oder 70er jahren
ein ehrgeiziges projekt darauf ausgelegt
die ressourcen der natur nachhaltig zu
nutzen
[Musik]
ein rennen system lief unten an den
kuppeln entlang
damit fing das regenwasser auf und
leitete es in eine 90.000 liter tank da
unten an dem kuppelbau sehen sie noch
die beton wölbung des tanz das wasser
wurde gefiltert und als trinkwasser
genutzt wurde
ein faszinierender man mit lebhafter
fantasie über alles sollte ohne strom
funktionieren erwachte sämtliches
material mit dem boot dorthin
gleichzeitig nutzte er baumaterial aus
der region er entwickelte zum beispiel
beton aus sand und muscheln
wir reden heute viel über unsere co2
bilanz und über die verwendung
natürlicher ressourcen in dieser
hinsicht war bobby 1981 seiner zeit weit
voraus
seine experimentellen bauten inspirieren
uns heute noch
die dächer sind nicht nur aus
ästhetischen gründen kuppel förmlich
ihre form soll sie widerstandsfähig
gegen anbrandenden stürme machen
[Musik]
die runde form bietet dem wind kaum
widerstand
außerdem stehen die häuser auf pfeilern
so blieben die wellen unter dem
wohnbereich
wind und wellen können den kuppel
häusern also nur wenig anhaben
aber mutter natur hat noch ein weiteres
ass im ärmel
wer so etwas plant denkt natürlich an
die gefahr durch stürme hurricanes und
wir wissen heute da muss etwas
unvorhergesehenes passiert sein
vier der sechs boden ragen noch aus dem
wasser
aber es ist nicht der wind der die
beiden anderen auf dem gewissen hat die
bedrohung kommt von unten
als lily 1981 ein zu hatte der komplex
drei schlafzimmer drei bäder und 200
quadratmeter wohnfläche
dabei war er 400 meter vom wasser
entfernt
das alles hier war damals strand
[Musik]
die gucken häuser sollen ursprünglich
gar nicht im wasser stehen sie werden
auf einer einsamen insel errichtet
was aber geschah mit dem untergrund
[Musik]
während einer heftigen sturm flut steigt
der wasserspiegel rapide an
1992 elf jahre nach der fertigstellung
trifft ein hurrikan der stärke 5 auf
florida
[Musik]
hurrikan andrew bringt es auf
windgeschwindigkeiten von über 250
kilometern pro stunde
bevor er florida erreicht verwüstet er
zunächst die bahamas
65 menschen kommen ums leben die schäden
belaufen sich auf rund 27 milliarden
dollar in den usa damals der teuerste
sturm aller zeiten
der wind deckte reihenweise dächer ab in
einem bezirk werden
117.000 häuser zerstört oder beschädigt
und auch pries kuppelbau bekommt die
volle kraft des hurricanes zu spüren
die bauten wurden überflutet der strand
weggespült der schöne traum eines
nachhaltigen lebens ohne strom hatte
sich in einen alptraum verwandelt
ein jahr später gibt popp ließ familie
auf und verlässt die kugel häuser aber
die natur macht weiter
[Musik]
die stürme und das klima in der region
hatte nie gedacht die veränderung des
bodens hatte er dagegen nicht
berücksichtigt
es stellt sich heraus dass erosion das
eigentliche problem ist
[Musik]
der golf von mexiko hat eine natürliche
nord süd strömung jeden tag fließt das
wasser hin und her
die unvermeidlichen sturmfluten haben
einen teil des strands abgetragen und
die küstenlinie verändert dadurch hat
sich die strömung verstärkt und folglich
auch die erosion
[Musik]
die insel wird allmählich vom meer
verschlungen und jeder neue störung
verschlimmert die situation
in der bibel steht ein schlauer mann
bauer sein haus auf stein ein dummer man
dagegen auf sand nun publi hat sein haus
trotz all seiner großartigen ideen auf
sand gebaut
menschen haben eine relativ kurze
lebenserwartung wir sie in einen strand
und denken was für ein toller platz für
ein haus wenn wir den selben stand im
verlauf von 300 jahren im zeitraffer
sehen könnten würden wir erkennen dass
er eigentlich eine sandbank ist etwas
das sich fortwährend verändert
jetzt liegen sie da wie ein gestrandetes
schiff
vielleicht ändert sich eines tages die
strömung und die insel kehrt zu den
kumpel häusern zurück
[Musik]
einst waren sie symbole des
technologischen fortschritts
heute sind sie verlassen in diesen
verfallenen bauten sind die echos der
geschichte hörbar sie künden von krieg
und terror vom erfindergeist und
menschlichen streben nach fortschritt